what they could do though at the least
they could do one of those things where
like
they allude in the frame someone's like
there
you see another spider-man outfit like a
cowboy hip shot from my
eyes
or you got like two cheeks yeah one
cheek here one cheek there
and then tomorrow you start to break
down
webbing and they're like that's the
energy
oh come on that would be cool
what's happening reject nation greg here
john here we going to watch from cosmic
wonders spider-man 3 no way home trailer
update
teaser coming soon can't wait to see
what the information is because that
means we got a prep for
something coming we got a prep to wake
up early what's going on everybody it's
warren welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and the other day i did
a spider-man trailer update video
promising that if i heard anything else
i would
update you all and that's what i'm doing
and it looks like we have some good news
as fan of your word
is seemingly coming pretty soon and i
want to know what you think in the
comments down below
do you think that we'll see toby mcguire
and andrew garfield
or do you think they'll save that for
the official trailer or do you think
they might not even show them at all
some things that happened with venom let
there be carnage that were kind of
giveaways that the trailer was coming
pretty soon are now starting to happen
with spider-man no way home
and also keep in mind that spider-man
both marvel sony franchises so typically
when they decide to release the trailers
how many months before the actual film
comes out
everything they do before the trailers
come out they're all pretty much the
same because they're coming from the
same people so let's talk about
what's happening with the spider-man no
way home trailer but quick reminder only
nine days left in my stormbreaker
giveaway all you have to do is subscribe
to my dude you gotta answer cosmic
culture
link is
did not catch my video the other day
something really awesome happened which
was a good sign that the trailer is
coming soon and that is the official
sony pictures germany account on youtube
i saw this tweet around logos to the
spider-man no way home logo
as i mentioned in that video companies
don't do this unless they're about to
start promoting
movies and you don't start to promote
movies unless the trailer is already out
or about to come out
because you can't really promote
something that people don't really know
about remember
our community our awesome community we
love this stuff so we look it up every
day
but the normal public i wait for you to
look it up it's kind of crazy to think
that some people don't really know
anything about the upcoming spider-man
film so this is a very good sign that's
some weird news
now another great sign that happened
today is that amazon now has
officially licensed spider-man no way
home
merchandise we're talking about shirts
and tank tops and shirts
this again is another really great sign
pointing towards the trailer coming out
relatively soon
now we've had some people speculate that
it's probably that's true
take notes on all this stuff grace
randolph over here beyond the trailer
said that they've heard it's coming out
in june or july
and i don't want to really get people's
hopes up in case it doesn't happen
but it is kind of seeming like it's
gonna happen in june or july
it's definitely happening in june or
july june is only
two weeks away and i'll also say i
also don't hope they show toby maguire
or andrew garfield if they are indeed in
this movie
i think we will see one of the villains
or two of the villains i think we'll see
doc
ock so that we're knowing that there's a
spider-verse element in here i think
we'll see like either you know electro
or green goblin most likely electro
since they were the two most public ones
we'll probably even see dr strange if
they were able to do spider-man far from
home
and not give in to showing you that
mysterio is really a bad guy
if they were able to show you the
avengers and game trailer and pretty
much not show you
so much of what happened for that movie
most of the movie they can do a trailer
without showing toby and andrew and at
least alluding to it i feel like they
gotta save that for they may be in some
way
trailer no i don't wanna have to don't
want that trailer let's see what's going
on but if they do i'm gonna flip the
hell out you know
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna love it
either way and here's my reasoning this
is actually what happened with venom let
there be carnage of course we waited
forever for that trailer of course it
was delayed a lot but we waited about a
year for that trailer from when it was
supposed to come out
but right before it did come out sony
kind of started doing the same thing
do you guys remember when warren said
like a long time ago i was gonna come
out remember how we reacted you know i'm
really i'm really sorry okay
i guess the photo was fake so
sorry about that guys yeah
it's it's
but in all fairness he was like the
first person to let me know
about the venom trailer before he's
always looking at before it did come
actually did come out here you redeemed
yourself yeah
they kind of started to promote it just
a little bit and then randomly one day
you could go to disney's official
website
and you could go to amazon and all of a
sudden you could buy venom let there be
carnage merchandise
so that day i did a video talking about
how that meant that the trailer is
probably coming pretty soon and then the
very next day
the trailer came now the trailer for
spider-man no way home is not coming
tomorrow if it does i'll be extremely
shocked but i'll be happy but do not
expect that it is most likely coming in
june or july if it comes out in one of
those months
before workout to get in the costumes
when they typically release teaser
trailers and the filming has been
wrapped for some time now giving the
editors plenty of time to create a
really awesome teaser trailer remember
it's just a teaser it's not a full-on
trailer so plenty of time to create a
good their teasers are like two minutes
it's like a sizzle reel on youtube which
means other sony pictures official
accounts will probably
do the same relatively soon and the fact
that merchandise official merchandise is
now becoming available on amazon and
will most likely be available
on disney soon bring on the toy leaks
very soon so of course as always if i
hear more i will definitely let you know
but in the meantime within the next
month or two it looks like we are going
to be getting the official trailer for
spider-man no way home and my question
to you is in the teaser and remember it
is a teaser not a full trailer
do we see toby maguire and andrew
garfield
yes or no let me know in the comments
down below don't forget to subscribe to
stay up to date on everything relating
to spider-man far from home don't forget
to like the video and for live streams
no
you can do it
of course absolutely thank you warren
for letting us know
always feel free to text me but i also
like checking out your videos but they
could do though
at the least they could do one of those
things where like
they allude in the frame someone's like
there
you see another spider-man outfit like a
cowboy hip
shop
or you got like two cheeks one cheek
here one cheek there
and then
all right guys well spider-man no way
home are you excited for the trailer
leave your thoughts down below i'd be
very surprised if you aren't
and if you aren't thanks for being here
clicking on the title of this video to
complain
subscribe
john i encourage you to shout out daniel
gallagher without mentioning a scottish
or a pharmacist daniel gallagher i just
hope that you're having
a good may right now it's a month of
flourishing
opportunities you're a learned young
chap
you got a beautiful boyish face
and uh i hope that you're just out there
living your life i don't know
what uh restrictions are like where
you're from
which i won't name by name but uh i hope
that you're able to get out there and
enjoy
things a little bit more because we talk
a lot about the work i won't mention
that you do
here and i hope that your life isn't
just about that because laughter and
joy and human experience are the very
best medicines
so yeah dan does anybody call you dan or
do you go by daniel are you one of those
guys who's like full name only
how did this end up longer than when you
actually have something to work with
this is insane all right daniel
appreciate john's efforts thank you